this is my fortress of solitude and none
of scout anonymous room anonymous hotel
portraits of trolls I must be hungry I
always get these thoughts when I'm
hungry
[Music]
this is Sedin this city is a labyrinth
designed to mock me
no don't count look I have to leave I'm
starving I can't stay in here all day I
can't leave
who's that man that a hot dog you all
caught up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know where the hot dogs from you
took away anything about couples who you
trying to fool
it's fine just hail a taxi it's already
a van again just whatever put up your
hand like a normal person
it'll be like a real New York how is
this happen to me why am i touching you
use my phone and make it come to you
make it come to you no confrontation but
this was supposed to be easy
CEO myself back in the bottle
I'm gonna die you could eat any of these
spaces look there's a bunch place right
now you're gonna beat so you can have
anything you want
come on to the trail to the hot dog
store
does anyone know where to get a hot dog
just asks that's an ice cream you don't
know what an ice cream is wait I think
it is it is this is the place looks just
like I imagined I've done it I've done
it I know you're good though I found it
for myself I knew it I knew it I knew I
was just a normal human being you can
call me wrong I eat hot dogs
[Music]